Paris Hilton seemingly addressing her
split with Chris dilka after ending
their engagement now just hours after ET
learned that Paris and Chris called it
quits the 37 year old Aires took to
Instagram like nothing happened she's
quoting Marilyn Monroe Katie not
surprised
quote people change so that you can
learn to let go you believe lies so you
eventually learn to trust no one but
yourself and she posted a clip of
herself dancing to Neos miss independent
playing in the background which I'm kind
of obsessed with because if Paris is
gonna do anything on social media of
course she's gonna dance around to write
independent that's a perfect way to
address it without really addressing it
but here's the thing
all signs kind of pointed to a happily
ever after between these two I agree but
our source close to the couple says that
the relationship was moving way too fast
in the beginning and she realized that
he wasn't the one for her and it just
wasn't meant to be so of course we know
Paris is not the type of person to just
settle down
I really thought all signs pointed to
them being together they seemed so in
love so that he's perfect for me in
every way I've never been so happy and I
just feel so lucky I love this man he is
my best friend
my everything there's no one I trust
more no one I've been ever so close to
in my life and I just feel so blessed
every single day okay Katie
so do you think that Paris could be
afraid of commitment
because she's the one that reportedly
called off the engagement yeah well
listen this is not her first engagement
it's actually her third engagement in
2002 if we want to go all the way down
memory lane she was engaged to Jason
Shaw they called it quits in 2003 and
we're gonna let that one slide because
she was only 22 it we don't know
ourselves at 22 guys exactly and then in
May 2005 she was also engaged to Greek
shipping heir Paris last teeth we were
obsessed with that because it was Paris
in Paris do you remember that yes that
is really cute glad I still don't know
if that would work yeah I mean they
broke up five months later and she also
famously dated Nick Carter Josh
Henderson so I don't know if I'm that
surprised by this breakup but I am
because they said nothing but great
things about each other and Katie of
course we know that they talked about
having kids together which is kind of a
first for Paris Hilton yeah you do make
a good point
in March I actually talked to her and
she had babies on the brain
take a look do you have baby fever at
all yet I can't wait to have a family
one day definitely I found the perfect
man to start a family with so I look
forward to that I would love twins
really okay so you guys are talking
about it though a little bit we've been
talking about it since our first date
yeah we've always known it's not the
beginning and in June so just a couple
months ago she confirmed that she had
found her dress and that her sister
Nikki Hilton was starting to plan the
bachelorette party so things were moving
along very seamlessly I think she was
getting excited about this she was gonna
invite Nicole Ritchie to the wedding yes
she had all of her wedding plans down
pat and so it really was surprising to
me I know a lot of people are like I
don't care but I do I do
Courtney cares about parents guys care
about pairs because I want her to be
happy and I felt like this could have
been third time's a charm I don't know
okay guys so do we think that Paris
should return the two million dollars
yes okay yeah California law guys it is
California law and since Paris
reportedly broke off the engagement she
has
to give the ring back but this is Paris
Hilton we're talking about I have a
feeling she might not of course we heard
that chris has not requested the ring
back and reports claim that he might
want to in the future yeah well we want
to know did you guys see this
relationship coming to an end were you
rooting for the whole third time the
charm thing with Paris and Chris break
let us know on social media I'm Katie
underscore Cramps and I'm Courtney
underscore teza know until next time you
got you covered for your pop culture fix